these black and white up on me
dont now why you like the grey
chill if you want to but I promise that I stay
we could be something and ı can be your everything
ay ay
you should be all over me
this should be simple find what your into
pick up the tempo ah ah
back in the limbo come to my recsue
put away come thru
and I might just do something new for you
I put away for you
come thru
la la la la la la
come thruuuu
Do as you want bae
Long as you're doing it my way
Got eyes on your foreplay
So make em roll back eh
You should be afraid
Forever's never guaranteed
eh eh
You should be
All over me
This should be simple
If i'm what your into
Pick up the tempo
Ahhh
Back bend the limbo
Come to my rescue
Put in work
Come thru
And I might just do something new for you
I put in work
For you
Come Thru
La la la la la la
I put in Work
For you
Come Thru
What I'm gonna teach you now
What you gonna teach me now
You put in that work for me
Do it perfectly
That keeps me down
Graduated from foreplay
I'm proud of ya
I'll bring the freak
Right up out of ya
Come from the front
But you like the back
Claiming that
That's the best side of you
I'll be your bachelor
Teaching you acrobatic sh*t
Backflips on mattress
Practicing till we master this
Call me your student girl
I'm tryna learn something new
Get the camera shoot it
Let's do this I'm tryna come thru
Put in work
Come thru
And I might just do something new for you
I put in work
For you
Come Thru
La la la la la la
I put in Work
For you
Come Thru